好 因為上兩周的時候我講的一半的時候正好不是出點意外嘛
以後我可能會避免講一些跟政治相關的東西
然後那個快到年底了其實 像是今天11月份
Zerchord的這些記報都出來了
其實去年差不多這個時候我們談到了對明年的展望
然後最近因為市場上有非常多的人在談論
就是AI左腳、彩右腳
美國的股市是不是創新高之後是個巨大的泡沫
然後要跑跑
然後有沒有 其實主要是有沒有tell risk
就是這個尾部風險
就黑天鵝事件一下子表現說暴跌很多
像去年我們其實覺得這個黑天鵝事件概率非常大了
然後今年會不會有
或者明年年初或者是年中之前會不會有這樣的一些風險
首先我在講這些東西之前
我先給一個我個人的結論吧
因為最近講這件事情比較多
一方面是因為AI相關的投資帶動這些公司的盈利
然後第二個部分是因為
從9月底開始美國有一些query market
就是信貸市場上的問題
query就是我們叫信貸和cds市場
那麼query和信貸市場的問題
其實主要是reginal bank的那些地區性銀行爆出來
那地區性銀行爆出來以後
其實讓大家關注到了後面的那個比方說car loan
汽車的貸款比方說cumberson loan的那些問題
那這個會不會是比方說明年發生一個尾部風險
我先給個結論
我覺得不太會
就是其實你看一個東西有沒有泡沫
我舉個打個不恰當的比方
這個東西就非常像一生看一個人血壓稿
就是你如果是這個血壓是9106
那就是肯定是高血壓
然後這高血壓會不會爆血管大概率不太會
因為他的壓差很大
然後那個但是如果是這個人的壓差很低
比方說這個人是140 103
那他很有可能會爆血管
那一樣的經濟裡面
就是我們不能只是去看有沒有泡沫永遠存在
比方說中國房地產泡沫存在幾十年了
然後爆了嗎
現在爆了
他之前沒有爆
然後那個美國股市有沒有泡沫
現在AI我認為開始是有泡沫的
特別是英偉達他們搞左腳踩右腳之後
確實是有泡沫
但是這個泡沫會不會爆呢
那就要取決於有很多的其他
我們就交易上的一些參數來看
我覺得不太會
現在的狀態和去年年底是不太一樣的
那去年年底是我覺得是有尾部風險的
那個是因為有很多交易上的參數
就是你看到他的這個頭寸的集中的程度
就是市場上大家頭寸集中程度都非常遠高
那現在看上去
我覺得沒有這方面風險
就是不是沒有這方面風險
這方面風險相對來說比較小
我待會會著重去講一下快樂的市場
就是信貸的市場
中美談判的東西你們可能自己看一下
然後我在這裡就不怎麼講
然後你們可能去關注一下
我待會會著重關注一下信貸市場
然後信貸市場為什麼
我覺得信貸市場雖然拉開了CDS
就是CDS就是相當於你可以這樣理解
就是一個公司站
它的這個價格要高於國債多少
那麼CDS不完全是國債的價差
但是大家確定買一個公司的這個信用保險
像CDS這個價格的價差拉開
那麼和CDS拉開相當於是變空
但是S&P還在漲
那麼這個是為什麼
是不是一個可持續的狀態
那我待會會簡單說一下
就結論是不太像會發生尾部風險的樣子
那個有各方面的原因
一方面CDS一方面利率
那首先先說一下那個經濟數據
因為美國政府官們已經關了快一個月了
這個我覺得待會會講到對Physical policy
對於那個財政政策
對於經濟的基本面影響
這肯定是負面
然後負面不是因為它僱員裁掉很多
而是因為它應該給的退稅
或者是應該政府花的錢
現在花不出去
因為它政府官們這個是有影響
你要看關多久
那你不可能永遠關下去對吧
然後大家關下去以後
共和黨和民主黨雙方的壓力其實都挺大的
然後因為政府官們
所以沒有出來很有效的經濟數據
唯一一個我們叫TA1
就是一類的經濟數據就是CPI
那麼CPI在那個比預期下了大概
比預期大概少20Basis point 0.2
比如我們預期大概少了0.2的樣子
然後這個數據的下降的原因
你要看分類
分類數據下降的原因
我經濟數據一比帶過
然後那個分類數據下降的一個很重要的原因
其實因為Shout房屋這個下降
但是房屋的數據下降速度比較快
也就是說很有可能這個數據是施增的
就是你們雖然看到這個CPI
是預期下降20Basis point
但是其實這個數據有可能會施增
那整體這個PCIe吧
就是說那個通脹的大概會有多少
就是通脹我們這麼看
就是Therov的影響和關稅影響
大概還在0.5左右
也就是我們覺得通脹大概在2.9到3
2.9到3對應的話就是2.4到2.5的實際通脹
就是那個把關稅這個影響去掉2.4到2.5
那麼這個呢就說我們看到就是對於去年的話
通脹還是我們不再往2%走
所以沒有看到通脹Spike up很快
那麼也就是說這個到時候我們會講到FOMC
FOMC的就是連儲降息
對連儲的政策影響也不會特別大
就是講到經濟數據我們會帶到一下
這個馬上要開的那個FOMC和今年
後面兩次的這個降息的到底會怎麼樣
這是我們現在只能看很多Ottenative data
就是替代性數據
這些替代性數據呢這個真實度多很低
因為現在人工採集通脹數據的工作也被停下來
這麼關門了嘛
所以很有可能10月份的CPR數據也會失征
就是這個數據失征的情況概率還蠻大的
現在就算現在看本10月份的這個經濟數據
就是真的概率還是蠻大的
所以每年儲很有可能後面兩次會議
它需要進入一種閉著眼睛開車的狀態
所以你當你閉著眼睛開車
你只能根據一些輔助性的數據
來判斷這個路上的路況
因為可能下雨 對吧
因為政府關門了
所以那個我們看一些輔助的經濟的狀況
這是一些比方說job opening
就是job opening就是開始招人的這些數據
包括一些私營其他的方面的經濟數據
其實還是顯示著我們現在的就業情況
是低於疫情之前的
因為你很像比較很長時間
那個趨勢還是低於疫情之前
所以通過上一次FOMC的這個態度
我們也瞭解到
就是說美聯儲現在的狀態肯定是往前開
就是你閉著眼睛開車
你只到車還開車你先搞清楚
它肯定是現在狀態是往前開的
然後因為閉著眼睛
所以它很難去把往前開的狀態改成往後看
這個非常難
因為你要從一個growth focus
你關注增長
轉換成關注通脹
你需要有證據的
你閉著眼睛政府關著門
你怎麼可能有證據的
然後聯儲裡面的幾個方面
第一個JAPO裡面本身是聯儲主席
是支持教習派
相對來說有一些是反對
但是JAPO肯定是屬於相對各派就支持的
然後10月份的數據不大確定
然後聯儲就更加難以去改變這一政策
第三個就是它也要去評估財政政策
對經濟的影響
這個是大概的財政政策的紅顏色線
我們就看紅顏色線偷偷
紅顏色線偷偷就是財政政策
對整個經濟實際的影響大概的狀態
你說我們會看到的是
現在的財政政策是收緊的
因為它加了關稅
然後接下去要放錢
放了錢以後
那個
關了錢以後對經濟的影響應該變正
但是先放不出來
因為政府官們國會不必預算
那麼這種情況
整體對失業情況的影響肯定是負面的
所以聯儲更加會傾向去降息
所以我是覺得美聯儲降息
大概要降兩次
今天會降兩次
但是不要期望美聯儲把利息加到1%
也不要期望它把利息加到很低
什麼1.5%之類的
我覺得不要敲這件事情
不可能發生
因為為什麽
這個是十年期利率
十年期利率現在在4%
今天第二來一點
大概在4%
十年期利率在4%
我覺得是個極限
那這個
這個待會我順便玩力去講一下
現在的膨脹
就是PCE
你哪怕把關稅給去掉
關稅不去掉是2.9到3
然後關稅去掉是2.4到2.5
那麽關稅不去掉在2.9到3的情況
因為你不能低於PCE的
你不能在現在的經濟情況下
去給一個負的實際利息
我們叫Naked real interest rate
這是給不出來的
所以你的降息一定是往下面有下限
如果現在狀態
就是聯儲現在無論是誰當政
哪怕是特朗普的小親信
就稍微有點confidence的人
他是股票漲了這麽高
對吧
還有黃金也在漲
你誰敢給一個Naked real interest rate
負的那個實際利息
沒人敢吧
沒人敢給負的實際利息
就意味著你降息就是有
這個子彈就是有限
我待會說信貸市場的時候
子彈是無限的
我會再說一下
就是這個中間有個區別
但是實體經濟上降息就是有限
所以你不要期望聯儲
那個絕票卸任之後誰上臺
能夠非常瘋狂的降息
降了很多
然後把那些
我們叫做自保類資產
表上自保類資產就是比特幣啊
這些東西
黃金是因為中國政府買
那個是另外一回事
那個如果是沒有買的情況下
把他們這些資產炒得非常非常高
我覺得不太容易
這一輪的周期
主要還是在政府花錢
在AI的需求很大
然後我們待會講到AI寶寶的時候
會說就是
這個本質是看它到底賺不賺錢
現在ROE還是很高的
ROE就是投資
然後投資帶來收益
然後政府又在花錢
是這個大周期
那麼說十年利率吧
這個大周期裡面
十年期的利率
因為政府還是要後面
因為你知道為什麼每一次
政府一關門這個利息就變得很低
這個是過去一個變
政府一關門利息
沒有供應嘛
那個不知道你發展沒有供應
那當然那個債就要漲
但是供應出來以後
你畢竟有這麼大赤字對吧
你明年DBO1的供應
可能有九百九億
九億多
我具體才看一下說應該有九億多
所以有這麼大的DBO1的供應出來
因為去年是七點八億
那今年是七點八億
然後債的供應不是看你發了多少料
債的供應是看你DBO1
就是一個basis point
然後整個對這個債券的影響
這個供應量出來以後
整個債券市場特別是十年期
我覺得是很難維持在百分之四以下
這個我覺得比較確定
這個信心還是很阻的
所以它如果再下來
特別是政府關門
一直沒有供應的情況下
可以去買swapping
就相當於swapping就是它的option
然後去做多十年利率
我覺得十年利率在後面穩定狀態上
是要遠遠比這個高
那麼最近市場兩大談到
那個我們叫做微不風險
就是可能黑天鵝事件的事情
第一個就是AIBO會不會破滅
AI是不是一個很大的泡沫
首先我覺得先講這個比較簡單的事情
AI是不是一個泡沫
AI不是
為什麼不是呢
因為有人說AI是中國的成頭債
中國一直在說這個事情
確實沒錯
可以是中國的成頭債
因為政府在花錢
然後企業在花錢
企業自己在借那個
相當於企業自己在造錄
那不還不完全是政府造
但是20000年的成頭債
是上海照地鐵
因為它投資收益高
那不是2020年的成頭債
那現在中國成頭債丟下去以後
是不賺錢的
我們看一下這是公司
但是可以那個可以參考一下
就中國投資收益率是11很低
美國投資收益率很高
人家是23人家估值高是有道理的
人家估值雖然是在95%
但是人家投資收益率是在95%
我們投資收益率低
就是你過度投資
你投資的方向都還不賺錢
那個美國那是AI這邊的是
AI是賺錢的
這個就是我們看上週的這個東西
其實這個是企業裡面
都是一樣的
那麼AI賺錢就是在於兩個方面
第一個它是那個給UserCase
UserCase就是像Ethopia或者是像OpenAI
他們這些人在訓練
然後第二個其實更加直接的是Digital Media
這個我之前也講過
就是Digital Media
你會看Metal和Google的財報就行了
就是他們對於AI的投入
是不是馬上能產出盈利
是不是馬上能提高
甚至能夠提高麻疹
他投進去錢能讓他毛利率上升的
那就是這個就沒有什麼明顯的
這個AI上的一個包裹
因為能賺錢嗎
能帶來錢呢
那麼所以這個先滑掉
也就是說AI左腳是有踩右腳的現象
那麼他什麼時候認為是這個包裹
就是你有沒有泡沫嗎
有嗎 有沒有高血壓有嗎
血管什麼時候爆掉
這不是我高血壓血管就會爆掉
血管爆掉像去年年底
那個我一直在說他有巨大的這個風險
是我們叫做石頭擠油的交易太多了
也就是說所有整個市場裡面
有很多套利的地方
或者有很多我賣出黑天鵝的
我賣出黑天鵝風險
然後獲得那麼一點點收益
比方說MyOption就是這種交易
那這種交易太多了
在S&P上MyOption
在CreditsBread上面MyOption
然後在SaleVo
他們都要SaleVo對MyOption
然後做大量抗感的
大量抗感去世跟隨交易
然後做VocantureStrategy
就是Vo很低我就加抗感買
那麼這些交易都很多
這些交易
而且是你看上去每個交易策略是獨立的
但是他們在極端情況下
這些交易的拋牌是一致的
就是做空
也就是你比方說
發生就大好會講到那個快利Market
快利Market為什麼跌那麼多
其實快利Market影響很大的時候
其實上週的話
是因為快利Option的Market出了問題
那就是當我賣Vo的時候
Vo上升市場劇烈波動
我要把這個Vo買回來
我把這個Vo買回來
把Option買回來
投行就要去賣出Option
投行就銷竿
投行銷竿
當市場跌的時候投行就做空
它無腦的 它對中盤就是做空
所以它會順著砸盤
然後它會砸得更深
那麼但問題是你如果像CDSMarket
比方說CDS上面Vo也會變大
那麼快利Market上它也砸盤
它把快利Spring搞得很高
然後在股票上面它也砸盤
投行也砸盤
然後它就把那個市場砸得很低
但是你會發現這些市場
都是同一方向的
當它爆倉的時候它就一起往下
然後在所有市場上全部砸砸盤
投行的對中盤都在砸盤
然後你這個交易就會崩掉
而且你從去年年底看的話
它的利率很高
這個十年期我沒有壞你
但去年年底的時候其實在4.5
市場漲量很高的時候在4.5
十年期利率在4.5
也就是說你造了一個很大的燕色壺
然後這燕色壺的水位還很高
你的壩還不夠不夠強
所以爆掉是一個誘因的問題
是一個時間的問題
就好像一個人他走在路上還很健康
看上去很健康
但是他那個血壓是135-140
他肯定要保學完
是這樣一個狀態
但是今年不一樣
今年現在狀態完全不一樣
因為首先VIX不高
跟去年想比VIX不高
VIX不高的差別是
VIX是你可以去衡量
整個市場上感冒Position有多少
因為特朗普這個人很悉悉古怪
他經常今天跟中國談
明天跟中國又鬧
就中國跟美國這件事情
就總結一句話
就永遠談不好的
永遠也不會打起來
就是一直搞
永遠沒底
一直搞到等到很多年以後
中國經濟徹底崩潰掉了
不是崩潰掉了
就慢慢被壓垮了
然後就不搞
這個是有可能的
但是中交會一直搞一直搞
所以他讓整個市場的WOW就變得很高
整個市場的WOW變得很高
賣Option的人其實沒有那麼多
就是說市場沒有那麼容易
在25的VIX
然後讓他們全部打爆藏
但是在原來比方說
Option在短期的Option
WOW在8% 10%的時候
他們很容易爆藏
因為10%到15%
他們就要在17、18、20%把它買回來
然後整個市場就Negative消乾嘛
但是現在的情況
沒有那麼容易消乾
因為它水位比較高
或者說你這個顏色
我的水位沒那麼高
那麼這是從VIX上面來看
第二個從利率高
我講利率上來看
那時候利率也很高
相當於你的利率高
意味著你的Risprimian就很低
Risprimian就是你要股票的收益減去利率
Risprimian就很低
現在要差50個幾點
所以你的整體的空間都會大很多
那麼第三個就是Quartus spread
當時的Quartus spread
CDS spread是最最低的
你記得我一年以前的時候
如果說真的要去兌充風險
你們就買CDS的Core
或者你們要去覺得這個市場不好
你就去買CDS
或者是你去甚至買CDS的Core
或者你買CDS買保險
因為這個東西對抗買那個公司破產保險
這個東西對抗發生的尾部風險的效率是最最高
對吧
你們記得吧
一年前
因為那個時候CDS非常非常便宜
大家認為所有公司都不會破產
沒有信待的問題
但現在不一樣
現在CDS很spread很高
或者很多
特別是發生這些事情以後
我簡單說一下當然發生了什麼事情
你可以看
這個是CCC的債券和BBB債券的spread
拉開了多少
然後Reginal Bank和其他銀行的spread
當然更長期一點的spread拉開
更多一點就是spread拉開
那本質上發生了一件什麼事情呢
就是9月初的時候
有一個叫5th third
5th third的一個銀行
對choccolon借款
choccolon的意思
它是借subprime column
subprime column你就可以理解為
我們以前有subprime mortgage
subprime的那個房屋底下大款
它是借subprime的那個汽車大款
然後這個汽車大款
它把抵押品給
把collateral的swift掉了
換掉其實就詐騙
那麼這個詐騙發生了以後
他們記憶損失了
大概就這樣就沒臉
沒有那麼多了
5th third
然後接著有個first brand
有個叫first brand
然後也是auto supply chain的公司的破產
然後接著在年報的時候
Zone Bank和West Alliance
對於West Alliance又被人家騙了
但現在有flot
又被整體記帖270個million的這個損失
所以大家覺得一般來說
信貸市場出問題
信貸市場是個挪勇的市場
你如果經濟很好
大家都還得上站的
然後那個利率沒有問題
你把collateral全拿出去
那個也不會出問題
但是問題現在
卡攏的這個汽車貸款的
那個違約率上升了很快
就是違約率上升
其他的longs
違約率沒有上升過的
沒有上升很快
那卡攏違約率上升很快
那麼市場有一個最主要的擔心
是覺得汽車貸款
違約率上升了很快
主要原因是經濟不好
我大會說這個不是一麽經濟不好
這個玩意是因為中國
那個中國農村包圍城市
把人家那個汽車市場給打崩掉
然後那麼這種情況
就會讓市場擔心就是我們有沒有
因為市場非常eliosynccy
就是叫什麼
ptst eliosynccy
就是這個他對於這種情況
發生他第一個反應
是不是2023年那個
sibb的事情回來
然後更怕的
就是說是不是2008年
這個subprime看上去名字一樣了
會不會2008年那個subprime mortgage是一樣
那個完全不一樣
我說一下為什麼這兩個東西
都完全不一樣
首先2008年的時候
是整體市場所有銀行手上持有了
大量的subprime mortgage
不管是它什麼品級的
比方說trick away的
它的滑法是
我把一個債券
比方說一堆mortgage
那個房屋抵押下去拿過來
我把那個中間的subprime
8%那個位置滑出來
就8%到10%
最先我約8%到10%
然後滑出來以後
我放在一個池子裡面
然後再分割一下
這個叫CDO嘛
然後這個最對上面那一層
優先的我就把給它三個A品級
是這麼搞的
那麼問題是你整個房屋
如果是違約率上去了
上去到8%到10%
這些所有三個A債券全部規定
那就是說
我們當年看到的
我入行的時候看到的是
整個市場上所有銀行手上
持有的那些東西都沒有克賴軸
等於是都沒有抵押品
全部是那個空的
那是系統性的問題
那現在是嗎
那現在肯定不是
因為現在從2008年之後
整個銀行業的監管
嚴格了非常非常多
它可以一次就個別的case
把那個抵押品給換出去
但是就比如說
我們現在看到那個地具性銀行
它們雖然分控能力差
但是它們手上拿的
都是強制押的貸款
不管是科摩索隆也好
那個卡隆也好
它的雖然違約率上升
但它強制押
制押率都在40以上
它沒有這種
像以前CDO一樣
就是所有的制押品
就會全部美的
系統性的沒有
它不是的
就是它這個是個single case
因為你回頭看
即用銀行的這個盈利率
雖然它集體了40個Mhz
40個Mhz的損失
但是
說錯了50個Mhz的損失
但是它有7個別的capital
然後這個quarter還是
雖然它有這個損失
這個quarter
還是它second most profitable quarter
就第二
就所有那個季度以來
第二有賺錢的季度
所以是不是對銀行體系
造成了信貸性的衝擊
肯定沒有
這個是絕對沒有的
因為有沒有後面比方說
整個房屋底下大款
全部破掉會不會影響
我覺得這個
現在也沒有看到房子
會大棍木的崩盤
所以我覺得現在
就你不能去預判一個
以後會發生的事情
我只能說
它這個現在的一個血管狀態
不會爆血管
就只能這麼講
然後那個
第二它會不會像2013年一樣
比方說
那個造成地區性銀行的大棍木
比方說破產
那也不會
那2013年的時候
是大家手上持有了大額的
就是因為銀行都是槓桿的
它主要同時都是買國債
國債從100個basis point
到了400個basis point
以上
450個basis point那個時候
那麼你想
這個是3到4個percent的影響
3到4個percent百分比的影響
10年期要乘以8
那個玩意兒是對整個
資產負債表往往是20的影響
那這些銀行全部自不抵債了
就資本驚動沒有了
但是你現在拿到的這個
這個卡隆這個雖然汽車
房屋的汽車貸款的影響
其實本質上沒有那麼大的
對資產負債表衝擊
Zion Bank的資產負債表
現在是770億美元
然後計期了5000萬美元
就沒有那麼大影響
市場有點過於PTSD了
就是一流辛苦急
有點過於那個東西
所以不像2008年
也不像2023年
但是為什麼CDS spread變得那麼大呢
那就是因為原來CDS spread上面
在那個特別是HGY
HGY是最最liquid
最最liquid那個high yield的這個ETF
像HGY上面賣Option人太多了
大家都在賣Option
這個邏輯我剛剛講的是一樣的
麥波
那麥波的時候
一旦一個方向走了以後
就市場往一個方向走了以後
好好的對沖頭春就是直接拋盤
直接拋盤
相當於現在在CDS上面的Putscure
是非常非常嚴重的
就是你買那個Protection
買那個Put的那個Wall
買Cold Wall沒有那麽高
那麽
但這個是不是影響整個
比方說股票市場的
股票市場的風險呢
我覺得不是
相反CDS spread拉開
給予整個市場更多的空間
這是我的看法
就是沒有這麽擠壓
這個橋沒有那麽窄
有一部分人先過橋了
當你真的發生一些什麽問題
大家要擁擠一起過橋的時候
沒有那麽多人了
所以你橋還是那麽寬
但是有一部分人先過橋了
他們已經包藏了
所以風險在釋放的過程
並不是那麽嚴重
第二個就是基本面
那我們說一下基本面的問題
那我最後
最後幾分鐘說一下基本面的問題
為什麽卡攏影響那麽大
汽車帶關係上那麽的
那你如果經濟真的是很差的話
你retail loan personal loan
和那個credit card
全部要一塌糊塗的
那08年的時候這些東西全部不行
那mortgage
mortgage就是股票那個房子在漲的
這個拋開
那這些東西為什麽和汽車是脫鉤了呢
這中間有個很重要的原因
因為中國人在搞那個農村包圍城市
這個是我
我正好是前兩天跟一個朋友吃飯
我覺得講了非常有道理的
跟我講到這個問題
那個中國汽車
按照成本價
沒有毛利在全世界搞傾銷
雖然它賣不到美國去
但是呢
它影響了美國和歐洲的二手車市場
你一個車的二手車就賣兩萬塊錢
那你現在小米比方說蘇器
它就是針對你兩萬
它是三萬美金
兩萬三萬美金新車
然後就針對你二手車
然後把你亞非拉市場給打掉了
亞非拉本身是消化你二手車的最重要的市場
所以原來新車是賣個歐洲美國的
然後他們把二手車再去賣給亞非拉
然後他們的新車銷售還是很穩健
但是當你二手車被砸掉了以後
二手車市場沒有了
新車就賣不掉了
所以你現在看比方說這一年以來
那個Hunger
那日本車毛利下降百分之五十
保世界毛利降到零
降到百分之五
那個奔馳的前三個季度毛利加百分之七十
然後就降到百分之六十九萬
就他們
就是我今年
我一年前我就說
中國車廠和歐美車廠的競爭
這就是英國部隊在打大清的部隊
它是完全兩套邏輯
它的成本邏輯和製造的邏輯都是不一樣的
就新的電車它是一體化的
就是特斯拉
像特斯拉那樣的
它是新式的軍隊
它不管你用什麼武器
它打你就是的軍隊就是切殘
你的車的疊帶的速度和你車的這個成本
你跟它不是在一個水平線上的
那個所以昨天
昨天就出來那個
這個一髮半腦體就爆炒
對吧
一髮半腦體就爆炒
爆疊
所以整個在車企行業裡面歐美
歐美日這三岸國家
在車企行業裡面的問題
還沒有完全暴露出來
所以汽車AutoLong
為什麼呢
因為二手車賣不掉
就最簡單
二手車市場在歐美已經被打爆了
你最後承接承底盤
接盤的一些地方
印度亞菲拉被中國的廉價車也幹掉
所以中國而且本身那些車
用新式的方法去做車
它也不求毛利
它毛利也是領
而且像小米這種
就是毛利5%的手機市場進去的
然後它去幹10%到15%
那個毛利的車的市場
還有我們外野蠻人
再把中國那幫人再捲一遍
然後再去捲境外的
所以你說那個歐美那些車廠
比方說日本車廠
它能不能整體降產能
因為中國車畢竟是倒不了歐洲的
它能不能降產能
然後把這個歐洲市場做毛利錯高
它也很難做得到
哪個CEO敢去降產能
然後較凝厲
較Revenue預期都不敢
所以他們互相之間捲在那個狀態
被中國從底層農村包圍城市
把農村捲了
它這個城市是必然要出問題的
所以車和車廠那個千萬不要碰
股票上千萬不要碰
什麼一法半導體
一法半導體我一年前最最看空就是這個票
它自己做那個車歸金片的
都要被中國人能夠捲死
它的這個前端市場是車廠
又要被捲死
是個非常非常看空的一個東西
所以車有這個問題
但是不要因為車
是覺得整個市場有問題
整個市場並沒有那麼大的問題
我今天大概就先講到這裡
再多講幾分鐘
然後看看大家有什麼問題
然後我們可以